[Music]
you
yongsan corporate president and chief
strategy officer of Samsung Electronics
welcome to the industrial Salama back to
Stanford University oh thank you for
having me again I need to have you here
tell us a bit about how the business has
changed in the eight years since you
joined the company well you know the
business is always changing so but I
think really last 10 years we've seen
drastic changes and part of that is
really to do with the mobility and cloud
that are really changing the way not
only we are using for social media but
also the way we can conduct our business
I think the BTB business tools all the
way to consumer experience is changing
because of the way we are using our
supercomputers in our hand 24 by 7 and
all the business models that we known
that we have known or disrupted and
that's really the big change we see it
so we think of mobility for Samsung that
means two things not only phones like
you talked about
but the automotive industry and a few
years ago Samsung made its acquisition
of harman how's that going and what have
you learned in the three years since you
acquired the company so mobility let me
just give you some one background and
then talk about Harman so mobility
basically we are really a norm company
right so we have you know we have a
lumber market share in the world for a
number of phones that are soared over
350 million phones a year as a Samsung
brand has over 2 billion phones that are
installed around the world so that
really has a tremendous reach to
consumers around the world and that
really helped us to become a global
brand but also we provide 5g Network now
so in many ways we are really betting
the future of network is going to be 5g
and Samsung is behind the much of
networks like what Verizon has done with
their fixed wireless deployment in the
US and Korea Japan and others that are
happening as well and then I think the
other part is that we also developed
some are conductors for mobile community
from radios to processors to memories
that are pretty much older phones out
there and when you think about talk
about Harman a little bit of the movie
the mobility in the car space why did
you make the acquisition and what have
you learned in the last year so three
years ago in fact it is exactly three
almost three years ago right it's in two
months three big jacks or three years
ago there are two primary reasons to are
we acquired Harmon one is really around
automation as you mentioned the other is
really around audio and as you know
Harmon is a iconic brand and I just
stand for 70 years from JBL brand all
the way to Mark Levinson to AKG the
Infinity a whole bunch of the brands are
really build well harmony at a number
one audio company in the world with our
video display we thought that audio will
be highly complementary so that's one
position really providing experience so
consumers that are complete audio with a
complete video and then on the top of
that we really believe the future of
automotive is going to be based on the
smart phone technology that we
experienced that are moving into our to
manage an extension of our 24 by 7
experience so if you look at the
tomorrow's car you will see the 5g
radios you see the whole bunch of
batteries and whole bunch of sensors and
whole bunch of ui/ux entertainment in
many ways a lot of that technology will
come from the mobile community we know
of it so in many ways for Samsung the
synergy would be bringing the technology
we developed into vertical market like
automotive and give consumers much
better experience so they are connected
24/7 using from ability to service from
your home all the way to your work if
you think about Samsung as a large
global company the technologies you
talked about semiconductor manufacturing
communication storage entertainment how
do you think about sharing technology
across the different groups in Samsung
and how do you deal with it on a
geographic basis so in a large company
it sounds like a great idea to share but
as you know large companies has many
silos and it is about you know - joining
the organization structure and managing
the complexity and overcoming those
barriers and it's it's not that easy
I'll tell you because if you think about
each business
you know whether it's a hundred billion
dollar mobile business whether it's an
80 billion dollar consumer some the
semiconductor business or fifty billion
dollar consumer business or ten billion
dollar Harmon business they all have
management they all have business
they all have focused their customers so
how do you communicate and share among
these teams are one of the challenges
and making sure we don't reinvent at the
same time bring new ideas quickly among
our teams so sometimes we create center
organizations like our AI Center around
the world support globally the idea is
supporting all of initiatives around AI
but that's an example of some critical
areas that we have shared equally then
we were embarked on global corporate
initiatives so centralize what makes
sense and give our tana me where it also
makes sense absolutely if you look
forward the next decade what do you
think will be the biggest areas of
change that will impact Samsung and
Samsung's customers well I think as I
mentioned earlier you know I think the
whole idea is going from what I call
physical products to now it's about
experience products and if you think
about our mindset in the past where it's
a product was in the center and we try
to develop experience around that but I
think now we have to be consumer in the
center and put products around those so
that we have a consistent experience
because they're all mobile they're all
connected we need to give a consistent
experience and it have to be open you
have to be able to use a bunch of other
tools products that can be able to take
advantage of so open ecosystem will be
very critical parts of initiative when
you think about Samsung historically
it's been a product company and
manufacturing products chips and the
like and yet in this world where the
customers in the center hardware and
software will become increasingly
important how do you bring those
capabilities inside of the organization
when maybe those skill sets don't exist
today so in first of all I would say
that even today's product if you look at
mobile phone I would say 80% of our
engineering is already software because
with our software you can you cannot
build that ecosystem you cannot provide
the kind of layers but I think the
future is about how
do you take advantage of different
software solution capabilities and be
able to create a conversion experience
so convergent means it's not just what
you know in one area but it is really
about combining skills from different
groups I mean you can really see example
would be like health today her agent
just helps buy syrup IT will impact
health and health will get changed by
the cause of IT technology like gene
sequencing would not be possible by
based on it so medical breakthrough in
biological breakthrough it had a benefit
of optical technology storage technology
and computer technology that enable to
decode human gene sequencing two
thousand three or four time frame right
last question for you you're based here
in Silicon Valley how do you think about
filling that bridge between Silicon
Valley and back to Suwon and Korea where
not only time differences cultural
differences geographic distance how do
you build that bridge so it is a a
challenge because of the distance also
because of the culture and because also
the way of the gravity age so you have
to really bring bright ideas take an
impact and they can get their attention
and we need to figure out how to go from
country road to highway of idea sharing
and that's a challenge and we to it not
only throw our own ideas but really
bring external ideas that are bright and
really the innovative people from Israel
to Austria to Germany Silicon Valley let
them all being part of that ecosystem
and I think building the ecosystem
builded high-wage part of our mission
young corporate president and chief
strategy officer for Samsung Electronics
thank you so much for coming back to
Stanford it's always great to have you
back on campus
thanks very much other component having
your class again thanks so much
[Music]